[LAUGHTER]
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Go,
little balloon, go.
You can do it.
Hey, it's a great launch.
VIMAL BHALODIA: How far
away are we from the--
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: 52 miles.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Oh, wow.
It's still going strong.
It's still pinging
regularly with locations,
and that's fine.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: My
good friend, Vimal,
is great at coming
up with crazy ideas,
and I love helping
him implement them.
And he told me about
his crazy, awesome idea
to send cameras up on weather
balloons, and I was all in.
I'm Heather Brundage.
I'm an engineer and explorer.
And I like to go on
crazy adventures.
VIMAL BHALODIA:
I'm Vimal Bhalodia.
I'm a serial entrepreneur,
software engineer,
and maker of random things.
ALL: We're the Casa
de Balloon Club,
and this is made with Android.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Launching
weather balloons
is kind of an interesting
engineering challenge.
Plus the fact that you can
get pictures of the earth
from 80,000 feet,
where you actually
see the complete
blackness of the sky
and the curvature of the earth.
And it's absolutely incredible.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
We used Android
because it was a very
affordable device.
Another reason why
we used Android is it
had fantastic documentation.
VIMAL BHALODIA: One of the
greatest things about Android
was that it was very
easy to pick up.
Literally just
downloaded the SDK,
read through the first tutorial
on how to build an app,
and then built the
first prototype of this
all in an afternoon.
Instead of using
this battery, we're
going to be wiring in
one of these holders.
Up above 30,000 to 40,000 feet,
the normal lithium batteries
that are sitting in
your phones will not
work all the way up there,
because they'll just freeze.
We actually have to
hook our phones up
to external battery
packs that are
using disposable lithium
primary batteries.
I actually do all this
in my living room.
I just have a little
bench, and you don't really
need that much to do
a project like this.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Our
most basic payload
is just an Android phone.
And with that phone, we're able
to get GPS location, as well
as altitude.
Android allowed
us to take control
of the phone in a low-level
way that we needed.
We're using these
phones in a way
that they're not designed
for, and other phones
don't let you do that.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So the app that
we developed for our balloon
launches is pretty
much the polar opposite
of a normal
well-behaved mobile app.
A normal well-behaved
mobile app tries
to be very careful
about power consumption.
It tries to play well with
all the other apps that
are running.
It doesn't want
to hog resources.
We want it to be
running all the time.
We never want it to sleep.
We want it to always be the most
important app that is running.
And make sure that, if
for whatever reason,
the phone reboots
because of a low power
situation or something, our
app comes up and running.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
That's something
that a lot of other phones don't
allow you to have access to,
but Android allowed us
to have that control.
VIMAL BHALODIA: And there's
our phone booting up.
Good times.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Checked the
weather for this Saturday,
and actually it looks fantastic.
Ahead of time, I end up doing
a lot of work on the computer.
And I'm looking at
wind simulations
to figure out a good
launch location,
as well as expected drop zones.
Checking that against
no-fly zones and airports
in big cities to make sure
that we don't have any issues.
And, oh, it'll
pop over Los Banos
and land a little
bit over [? Fibra. ?]
VIMAL BHALODIA:
That's not a bad area.
Nice.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Sweet.
So it looks like Saturday's
going to be good.
We do run extra predictions
right at the time of launch,
since wind predictions are only
so good, and they can change.
VIMAL BHALODIA: I'm going to
be preparing the payloads,
putting in the batteries,
turning on the phones.
Just doing a final
check to make sure
all the software is running.
It looks like it's working.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: We've also
added in an Android camera.
So it's not a phone.
It's specifically a camera.
So it's much better
than the camera in just
a regular Android phone.
VIMAL BHALODIA: There are
a lot of different things
to worry about in
these payloads.
We have a bunch of
trade-offs with respect
to weight, power
consumption, the electronics
and their sophistication.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
So you guys ready?
ALL: Yeah.
VIMAL BHALODIA: At
the day of the launch,
we have a minimum
of three people.
We have the helium person,
the balloon person,
and the lift person.
And then, ideally, we also have
a fourth person with us, who's
reading off the directions.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Slide balloon neck
approximately three inches over
the PVC balloon fill nozzle.
VIMAL BHALODIA: This is
by far the hardest part.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All
right, helium fill.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Ready
FEMALE SPEAKER: Go.
VIMAL BHALODIA:
Ooh, he's perfect.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Great.
VIMAL BHALODIA: All right.
Then we tie the
payloads to them,
let them go, cross our fingers.
ALL: Three, two, one.
Woo.
[LAUGHTER]
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Go,
little balloon, go.
You can do it.
Wow, that's really
awesome to see.
Oh man, look at that
it just [WHISTLE].
Yes!
Once the balloon is in the air,
we're actively tracking it.
We have two devices in there.
They're both sending
us GPS location.
So they're close.
They're a little
off from each other,
but you can see she's
drifting southeast, ever
so slightly, which is
exactly what we expected.
We do lose contact
with the balloon
at about 20,000 feet, when
it leaves cell reception.
The cell phone is still
getting GPS data up
to about 60,000 feet, when
it then loses GPS data.
When the balloon
rises, it expands.
And when it gets high
enough, it bursts.
And that's when the
parachute deploys,
and it starts to
descend back to earth.
At this point, it's falling at
about five meters per second,
with a parachute.
And it's spinning around.
So it takes it a while to get a
cell reception and a GPS lock,
once it gets below there.
It could land on a
freeway, which we hope not.
It could land in a farm field,
or it could land in the water.
We don't know.
VIMAL BHALODIA: The
worst possible thing
that could go wrong is
that the payload actually
lands on a road or
inside a crowded area.
And we take a lot of precautions
in choosing both our launch
site as well as our
expected landing site
to make sure that that's
not going to happen.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: We could just
lose the balloon completely.
Have no contact with it.
The batteries could die.
The phone could stop working.
The program could
crash and not reboot.
And if we don't hear from it,
we're not going to get it back.
VIMAL BHALODIA: About
half the launches
that people have done
and blogged about,
they never saw again.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Hey,
to a great launch.
ALL: Cheers!
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
To a full recovery.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Oh, whoa.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: She
went pretty far south.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So
it's in a field.
We don't have to worry.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Yeah,
right in a farm field.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Perfect.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Let's go pick it up.
This is a perfect day
for Central Valley wind.
It was exactly as we usually
expect, a nice southeast wind.
VIMAL BHALODIA:
Yes, I'm about as
zoomed in as I can possibly be.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: And here,
wait, let me show you the map.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So one
of the great things
about using an Android phone is,
actually, in addition to using
GPS, also using network
triangulation, so we
have a much more
accurate location
spot, down to a couple of feet.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
I'm just hoping
there aren't, like, snakes.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Or sprinklers.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Yeah, or sprinklers.
Typically, we can see the
red parachute sticking up.
This time, we couldn't, so
we had this big, green field
and no red dot.
So we had to start
tromping through the field,
but, finally, we got right on
top of it and there it was.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Found it!
ALL: Woo!
VIMAL BHALODIA: Woo.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Awesome.
The Android device knew
where it was well-enough
and was able to communicate
its location to us well-enough
that it led us right to it.
It was a homing
beacon effectively,
just purely through GPS data.
And, even if all we knew
was, hey, it's in this field,
it would have taken us forever.
A combine would have
found it before we did.
We would have had to fly
over the field to see that.
VIMAL BHALODIA: There we go.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Oh,wow.
Oh my goodness.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Yeah,
everything is still pretty safe
and solid and secure.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Oh, man.
Look at this.
MALE SPEAKER: It just
tied itself into a little
[INAUDIBLE].
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Wow.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So here is
our happy, reliable phone.
It's been ticking along.
It is still on.
It has a great connection too.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Awesome, let's.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Everything
looks to be intact.
When we recover the payloads,
we bring computers with us,
and we like to look
at the pictures.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Which is really
satisfying at the
end of a long day,
to see these pictures that
you've just retrieved.
If other people are interested
in doing ballooning,
our code is open source
and available online.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Everyone who
does this has their own site,
and has their own blog,
and tells their own story
about their launches, and their
payload, and their experience.
And we've read a ton of them
and learned a lot from that.
And we also want to share our
story at casadeballoon.club.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: (HELIUM VOICE)
We are Casa de Balloon Club.
VIMAL BHALODIA: (HELIUM VOICE)
And this was made with Android.
[LAUGHTER]
The problem with regular
lithium batteries
is when it gets really, really
cold, they stop working,
so that's why we had to switch
lithium primary batteries.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: All right.
Take it away from me.
Oh my god.
VIMAL BHALODIA: We're done.